[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof hi Walter hi Martin are
we shaking things up no they're shaking
them themselves we've got nothing to do
with we've got nothing to do with It's
Just
Happening well before we get into this
let's open with a word of
Prayer our heavenly father we are living
in very tumultuous times and we cannot
go ahead if you are not with us so we
ask please enlighten our minds with the
Holy Spirit and that that we do the
things that you want us to do in Jesus
name
amen Martin when the image of the Beast
is
formed then uh we can expect the final
events to take place will that be also
then running up to the healing of the
wound yes the wound will then be uh
healed to the point where their
legislation becomes International
legislation enforced by the second beast
the United States of
America now we've been talking a lot
about this so our backdrop I think is uh
well rather
interesting you have that fist coming
out of the ground power to the
Beast and there's an interesting emblem
on that uh wrist wrist over there which
is of course the vatican's
emblem and then you have the capital in
the back with the goddess on
top so Martin where are we in the Stream
of time and what do the events of the
last few weeks tell us shall we start
with a little dance Martin yeah maybe
it's a good thing but people might
become confused and think that we are
taking sides here no we're only happy
that the end is near and that we can see
prophecy unfolding before our eyes
exactly so don't get um ideas no don't
get funny ideas
[Music]
[Applause]
s darus Smith with a
sack well check the flag here it was
[Music]
[Applause]
thrown so Martin if the second beast is
going to give power unto the first Beast
Roman
Catholicism then we can expect a lot of
these agents hidden in all of these
societies and uh groups that are
endeavoring to get this power enacted
yeah of the first beast of the first
beast and they have lots of time because
they plan not over years or decades or
centuries they plan over
Millennia so you and and another thing
is some sometimes they are in plain
sight and you you get fond of the
ideologies that they have or they induce
a fondness so that is
wondering receiving the mindset of the
Beast so let's make a disclaimer so that
even if we do a jig
Martin that doesn't mean that we are
jigging because we are in favor of the
ideology we're jigging because we could
be going home soon yes for sure for sure
when they sing the song of Moses and the
lamb Miriam did a little dance didn't
she with the tambourine so maybe we can
do one too so Martin let's go back and
look at the role players in the Heritage
Foundation the so-called battle between
the economic forum and the Heritage
Foundation ideology all part of the
heelan dialectic to receive this mindset
for sure so let's have a look at some of
this information one thing that Davos
you might say and the people come here
stand out for is liberal democracy so if
the idea that's going to be swept under
the table is part of the idea hopefully
that's not what he means what do you
mean what do you think it means by
retribution well it's laughable that you
would or anyone would describe Davos as
protecting liberal democracy with all
due respect nothing personal but that's
your part of the problem political
Elites tell the average people on three
or four or five issues that the reality
is x when in fact reality is y that was
Heritage Foundation president Kevin
Roberts holding nothing back as he
schools Global elitists gathered in
Davos about who the real threats to our
freedoms are Kevin Roberts joins us now
with more of his message Kevin we were
watching Rachel and I both have the same
question did they invite you did you
crash the party how did you end up
there oh man I they invited me I I never
would have gone there on my own valtion
and in fact when the invitation arrived
at Heritage Pete I told my staff y'all
are playing a joke on me I've not been
invited to the world economic Forum but
I'm glad I went because just real real
quick Point here which I know you and
Rachel not only agree with but you
really personify every time you're on TV
you know that the average person is
really frustrated with what
self-appointed Elites tell us and so
it's a privilege it's the greatest
privilege of my life to go speak on
their behalf no doubt so you were there
on as part of titled a panel entitled
what to expect from a possible
Republican Administration so is were you
almost there like were you were you
meant to be kind of like a zoo animal
for for the for those at Davos like who
are these Republicans that might take
power
again yeah that's how they looked at me
especially after the panel you know as
you might imagine there were only a
couple people who came up and told me
they agreed with me in in fact it
reminded me of when I was the one
Conservative Christian professor in the
entire College of Arts and Sciences at a
major university in the southwest so I
guess to some extent I've got I've had a
lot of experience with that kind of
thing and and I kind of relish it
because when we get the opportunity as
y'all know to speak truth to power and
to do it eyeball to eyeball there is
nothing more satisfying absolutely and
so it seems as if uh the one side has
now taken the ascendency right it seems
like it over the other side so the
hegelian mindset shift
by creating the ridiculous you get to
the synthesis
remember how many years ago when you had
the rhetoric that we have to drain the
swamp the whole time the world economic
forum and all the global
elitists and then the Biden
Administration took over and actually
furthered this agenda to rile up the
people even more to move them to another
position cuz you have to move the left a
little bit to the center and the right a
little bit to the center so that you can
get this synthesis so what did we say
the whole time we said that the pendulum
will swing will swing and now it did so
now people will get sympathy or will
stand with what we've just seen now M
what's fascinating to me is that the two
that are in that video that we just
played the one is Pete hex St who's now
being nominated as defense secretary now
that's a fascinating thing and the other
one Kevin Roberts is part of the
Heritage Foundation now Martin didn't
Trump isolate himself or distance
himself from that ideology in order not
to totally alienate the Democratic vote
yeah no completely so it's very
interesting how these role players come
together and we need to know who are
they and what are they doing
what do they belong to and does it
further the agenda of the first Beast
exactly because we can easily get on the
bandwagon and want to join Behind these
guys because they're bringing such a
logical message against this backdrop of
you know excessive liberalism yeah yeah
so let's have a look at what Kevin
Roberts actually has to say and what
what he stands for yeah let him speak
for himself if if I were as a Roman
Catholic if if I were sitting with my
family or with friends in this room in a
in a Catholic setting I could speak in a
certain way the difficult thing for
those of us who are in politics is that
you know even at Heritage where we're
really zealously focused on policy not
elections policy outcomes often are
determined by who wins the election so
we have to pay attention to the
elections the the the challenge for us
is we feel like Rome Washington is on
fire
and that there isn't enough time but in
fact we are on God's
time and it's TR to say that but we also
know that it's true and we know that
mother Church doesn't think in terms of
days and months and presidential
election Cycles she doesn't even think
in terms of decades she thinks in terms
of centuries and Millennia and I have to
tell myself as an American
exceptionalist a historian of the
American founding who loves this country
and can never give back to it what she
has given to him that even America can
get it wrong sometimes well Martin it
seems mother church has taught him
well she thinks in terms of
Millennia and her aim is to get the
power back yes that she lost that's the
main AIM now which organization Martin
is the one that was raised up to count
act the reformation and get that power
back the Jesuits yes that was the whole
aim of the Jesuits they've done a good
job educating most of the role players
that we're dealing with in the first
place including the presidents and their
children so it doesn't matter which side
so let's have a look at Kevin Roberts as
architect of project
2025 the guardian tells us that he has
close ties to the radical Catholic group
opest day God's
work that's what it stands for and these
people are known for wearing bracelets
that uh cause pain to remind them of
their obligation towards mother church
so their their efforts are aimed at
restoring the power of the
papacy so when the image of the Beast is
going to to give their power unto the
Beast then that is quite
incredible
so according to the guardian he has
close ties to Opus day so the Heritage
Foundation president and architect of
project
225 the conservative think teac road map
for a second Trump presidency has close
ties and received regular spiritual
guidance from an opus day Center in
Washington DC a hub of activity for the
radical and secretive Catholic group
Roberts acknowledged in a speech last
September that for years he has visited
the Catholic information center a K
Street institution headed by an opus day
priest and Incorporated by the arch
dices of Washington on a weekly basis
for mass and
formation but we need to speak about
this formation a little bit more don't
you think so we definitely have to
because that has infiltrated
Christianity and and that comes from the
exercises of Lala yeah which make the
experience nominative instead of the
word a very dangerous precedent
especially where we live now in the time
that we live now and if Satan will be
masquerading himself as an angel of
Light yes it's very important so Opus
day also organized
monthly Retreats at the
cic Gareth Gore the author of the
forcoming book on Opa day said members
of the Catholic organization are engaged
in a political project shrouded in a
veil of
spirituality could that be an osian
spirituality for sure that's why that
formation is spiritual formation this
was the weapon to destroy protestantism
get away from a word based religion to a
senal religion and one that is
experience based and not word
based the group's founder St Jose Maria
SCA saw his followers as part of a
rising militia Gore said who were
seeking to enter battle against the
enemies of Christ now we must understand
in this thinking that they have this
Christ is not necessarily the same
Christ as the Bible right that's very
important Roberts had said he is good
friends with JD Vance Trump's running
mate and Vance has praised project
225 as having some good ideas they have
to be careful how they phrase their
phrase themselves right V who converted
to Catholicism in 2019 also wrote the
forward for Roberts forthcoming book
praising the author for articul ating a
genuinely new future for
conservatism we are now all realizing
that it's time to circle the wagons and
load the muskets in the fight that lay
ahead these ideas are an essential
weapon Vance wrote now Martin one of the
the techniques that Rome has used for
centuries is to infiltrate
denominations and
organizations as Protestants and once
the main objective has been achieved
then they can openly go back to what
they were before or what they envisioned
I'm not saying it is the case here but
uh it is a distinct way in which they
operate remember Cardinal Newman yes he
was never Cardinal Newman until he had
actually completed the job of the Oxford
movement to destroy
protestantism and then he was rewarded
as a Roman Catholic Cardinal yeah so he
left
protestantism so are these muskets ready
to be loaded or the wagons ready to give
the power back onto the Beast I think
for sure it's interesting to see that
all the cabinet members of trump the
appointees and we'll see that they all
have affiliation with the Kevin con
Roberts and his Heritage Foundation yes
and they are probably highly aligned
with what the Roman Catholic agenda
really
is it's just also interesting like you
mentioned before you've got thesis and
antithesis so you have the world
economic Forum with CLA Schwab and all
his cronies yes and now you've got the
Heritage Foundation and all their
cronies yes and this is almost
like they're against each other but for
the greater good they're actually
they're actually part of it you know
this is this is a ying-yang philosophy
yeah you can be a member of the Church
of
Satan or you can be
illuminated and be on the light side
rather than the dark side and
irrespective of which side you're on the
king or the queen as it was in the past
would Knight them yeah it's like black
magic and white magic yes this is
exactly what it is for the greater good
now let's have a look at uh Pete
hexad and this is also very interesting
this is the Times of
Israel and they're saying that Trump's
nominee to lead the Pentagon has
multiple Christian and crusader inspired
tattoos now these are tattoos of Roman
Catholic orders secret societies I mean
the one on his chest there for example
so his tattoos political views and
religious affiliations and background
are consistent with an extreme strain of
Christian nationalism according to
Matthew Taylor a scholar of the
institute for Islamic Christian and
Jewish studies specifically appears to
belong to a French
denomination known as reformed
reconstructionism now we've dealt with
that
before this is power religion
power and secular power so this is the
image of the Beast to its Perfection but
who is it supposed to elevate isn't it
the first piece exactly are we seeing
this Martin
oh so what do they believe in which
believes in applying biblical Christian
law to society now this is where the
catch comes in because this Christian
law is not biblical law but Catholic law
that is the Crux and it differs yeah
from Biblical law and the Bible is very
clear in vain they worship me teaching
for Doctrine the Commandments of
men and it's of course exclusively male
leadership and actively preparing the
world for the prophesied return of Jesus
Martin which return of Jesus are they
waiting for if they want to build the
kingdom down here and the ible is very
clear that the kingdom is not of this
world but will be set up by Jesus
himself can there be a
millennial
Reconstructionist uh Kingdom before that
surely not no and that is why it will be
so dangerous because Satan will be
coming masquerading himself as that
Jesus yes one of ex's most prominent
tattoos is a large Jerusalem cross on
his chest a symbol featuring a large
cross potent with smaller Greek crosses
on each of its four
quadrants the symbol was used in the
Crusades and represents the kingdom of
Jerusalem that the Crusaders
established so this is a Heritage from
the Knights Templars yeah and remember
that to be a knight's Templar is one of
the highest orders that you can achieve
in Freemasonry as
well hexed also has deos Vault Latin for
God wilz it tattoos on his bicep
the phrase was used as a rallying cry
for the First Crusade in
1096 it is also the closing sentence of
hex's 2020 book titled American
Crusade the slogan has been used by
members of far-right white supremacist
and Christian nationalist groups now M
the way in which that is written of
course is written from the other side of
the perspective so read between the Lin
but uh the facts are nevertheless what
they are exactly the ideology behind it
might be a little bit extreme so so they
they gave they give it a bit more meat
than should but you can see what's where
it's heading what else does he have he
also has a cross and a sword tattooed on
his arm which he says represents a new
testament verse and the verse is Matthew
10:34 which says do not think that I
have come to bring peace to the Earth I
have not come to bring peace but a
sword Israel Christianity and my faith
are things I care deeply about hex they
told media Inc he has also said that the
idea of rebuilding the biblical temple
in Jerusalem's Temple Mount is a miracle
that could happen in our
lifetime so here we have basically a
crusader who is now spearheading the
military the most powerful military on
Earth yes well Trump says he's going to
make sure that it Remains the most
powerful on
Earth so Martin was America raised up to
be the military arm of the
Jesuits yes didn't Maryland belong to
the Jesuits doesn't the white out stand
on Jesuit
ground what this is all very
fascinating hidden under a Garb a lamb
like
gar when something is lamb likee is it a
lamb
no that's an interesting point don't you
think very because people tend to miss
that portion in the in the in the
prophecy yes like unto a lamb unto a
lamb so this project
2025 that Donald Trump tried to distance
himself from it seems like his
administration is very much part and
parcel of it rather than distant from it
for sure now the other interesting thing
is we've always said that it doesn't
really matter which party wins right
we've always maintained because both
parties according to the Jesuits
themselves uh remember we mentioned
quickley who said it doesn't matter
which party is involved so let's hear
from Roberts what he has to say on the
issue and really not that at Heritage we
feel either in entitled or defensive
about project 2025 we just are Resolute
because it's now policy-making season
this is something that we've done for 44
years since 1980 with Ronald Reagan we
understand that of course
president-elect Trump and vice
president-elect Vance will make all the
decisions having said that project 2025
is the single greatest biggest scope of
personnel and policy work that's ever
happened and we're very proud of it it
represents several dozen million
Americans if you think about 110
organizations who are part of it once
again totally up to the president-elect
and vice president-elect we operate in
service to them and to the American
people but ultimately to get to the art
of your question Joe the American people
have won here and we look forward to
playing whatever role formally or
informally that we can to support that
well I just did you anticipate the
backlash you mentioned Ronald Reagan the
Mandate for leadership was something
that was actually pretty well received
as a policy paper it helped to put
Heritage on the map was this supposed to
be another version of that or or sort of
a policy paper that you would provide uh
whatever the incoming Administration
would be it is very much designed as all
of our previous projects have been
designed which is to be of service and
if if I had to predict the next
Administration is going to be filled
with excellent men and women not just
because of the work we did but most
importantly because of the great Acumen
of the president-elect and vice
president-elect and the team that
they're already assembling um we learned
one name uh just over the weekend it's
Tom homman uh who's going to be the
Border zar as Donald Trump is referring
to it that was from a post on Truth the
Tom hman is also a visiting fellow at
Heritage he's a good friend I was
texting him earlier congratulating him
on that and look the most important
thing forget Tom's professional
affiliation forget that he was a project
2025 author the most important thing is
that he is aligned not just with
President Trump but also with the
American people who want to bring an end
to the the ridiculous disorder on the
southern border Tom's going to do a
great job there in other words Joe
neither today nor a year from today am I
going to be sitting in my office in
Heritage sort of keeping score about
who's in the administration and not
that's not why we do what we do we exist
every day to be of service to the
American people and to the
administration for that matter if the
Democrats had won and although it would
have been very surprising for them to
have called us and say you got a name
for so and so agency we would have done
that too this this is the whole point
about the work that Heritage does
understood so Martin did he say it went
back to the times of Ronald dragan yes
they were instrumental in the Ronald
Reagan Era with that whole uh running
and getting the holy Alliance thing
going now this holy
Alliance they tried to create diplomatic
ties with the Vatican under Truman
already and the Protestants in America
made such a
hooa that that never floated yeah they
couldn't get it past
and then Ronald Ragan came and
unilaterally just did it but didn't he
was he not almost also ex um
assassinated well Martin it's
interesting that both he and John Paul
II experienced a similar occurrence I
often wonder about those things and uh
you know I'm almost like the doubting
Thomas I would like to see the marks of
the bullets but we have been denied that
privilege it's interesting that uh the
Beast also received a mortal wound and
lived and it seems that Ronald Ragan who
created that diplomatic uh Union
received a wound and lived and the other
party John Paul II similarly also
received a wound and lived and both
popularity just shot up it it's like a
script of a movie are we in a movie I
don't know it looks it's it's very um
peculiar okay now they spoke about the
bordar the new man who's very firm on
this issue and he's going to rectify the
issue and he has ties to project 2025
yeah he wrote an article one of the
chapters or something I don't exactly so
how can one distance oneself from this
if the whole Administration seems to be
involved right true so are they going to
work closely with Donald Trump or are
they not let them say for themselves
even if they don't do it directly
through the rest of the administration
that's there it will be done well let's
see what happens let's see what they say
have you talked to Donald Trump since he
won uh We've not spoken yet but I
anticipate that we will I mean he's got
to be pretty keyed up on what heritage
is offering here uh he was on the record
when the team was trying to distance
itself from you I have no idea who is
behind it he put on X I disagree with
some of the things they're saying and
some of the things they're saying are
absolutely ridiculous and abysmal do you
have a sense of what he likes or doesn't
like here I think the key thing is that
President Trump saw the The Branding as
a liability in the political season but
I also would anticipate moving forward
that the president-elect and vice
president-elect with whom we maintain
great relationships will also understand
that it's the policymaking season that
Heritage and all of the other groups are
a part of our project are built for and
if they're looking for example as
president Trump said this morning to
dismantle the US Department of Education
we know exactly where he can go for that
plan totally up to him about whether he
uses the plan but that's that's what I'm
talking about Joe when I mentioned that
great ideas and great people rise to the
top the all of the political
calculations of the last few months
which were very understandable and about
which we have no hard feelings are in
the past we're now in the policymaking
season we think that this is the
beginning of a golden era of
conservative reform this is the
conservative reform this will truly be
the Golden Age of America that's what we
have to have many people have told me
that God spared my life for a reason and
that reason was to save our country and
to restore America to
greatness and now we are going to
fulfill that mission together that we're
going to fulfill that mission I will say
that because the work of project 2025
represents the conservative movement it
would be very difficult for anybody to
implement policies on education on the
border on taxation without at least
Consulting those ideas and people that's
not some arrogant or hubristic comment
on our part that's just the nature of
how policymaking Works Martin this is
all very interesting so that was just
policy that was just uh
electioneering so this is really the Hub
and they're going to dismantle the
Department of Education they've said it
on numerous occasions Martin who were
the school masters of Europe Jesuits the
Jesuits and didn't they bring that
school Mastery to the United States and
the entire world uh and Martin Luther
had said that if the Bible is ever
removed from the school that'll be a one
way oneway road to petition right and he
envisioned that if this were to continue
for a 100 years then they'd have to
start the Reformation all over
again now what's interesting Martin is
that they've used there also a kind of
heelan dialectic yeah so being in
control of the education system you push
it over the brink so that it becomes so
ridiculous that it needs
dismantling and then you bring it back
and you bring the Ten Commandments back
and you bring the Bible back but you've
totally changed the mindsets about the
Bible you've replaced the Bible with
experiential religion so it's not really
a threat anymore it's just sort of like
a historic document that's lying over
there
and then you bring your own set of
Commandments contrary to God's
Commandments and then the Beast is in
control that's it and because people are
so um brainwashed through all the ages
now they don't even realize that it's
the Commandments of Rome and they think
it's wonderful we're going back
to sensibility here yeah wasn't it also
interesting that they were both talking
about a golden age for America isn't
that new age talk that is new age talk
and maybe it is
reconstructionism so what is what do we
have here Donald Trump camela Harris did
nothing as
120,000 Armenian Christians were
horrifically persecuted and forcibly
displaced in artak Christians around the
world will not be safe if camela Harris
is president of the United States when I
am president Donald Trump said I will
protect persecuted Christians I will
work to stop the violence and ethnic
cleansing and we will restore peace
between Armenia and azerbajan
now he's coming forward as the champion
of Christianity yeah and the big
Peacemaker but look at his team what is
this Christianity that is champing it's
actually dominionism and Catholicism
100% these are Knights these are
Catholic Knights if they're associated
with opa's dead and remnants of the
Templars then they are under Jesuit
jurisdiction they're the militant arm of
the of the
Catholics Christians elected Donald
Trump so he can finish what Jesus
started
Martin do you think that Jesus needs
someone to finish what he didn't finish
well you will let prophecy then F be
fulfilled I think we could say maybe
Christians elected Donald Trump so that
he could fulfill the prophecy that Jesus
had predicted how about that I think
that's correct Donald Trump needs to
thank Jesus Christ for his election in
case you missed it 62% of Protestants
and 56% of Catholics voted for Trump
while 79% of Jews and 72% of atheist
voted against him this means Trump's
mandate is to finish what Jesus Christ
started and here is what Jesus
started Jesus went straight to the
temple and threw out everyone who had
set up shop buying and selling animals
for sacrifice he kicked over the tables
of the lone sharks and the Stalls of the
dove Merchants saying my house was
designated the House of Prayer you have
made it a hangout for
thieves now there was room for the Blind
and the crippled to get in Matthew 2112
to14 well it's not the King James
version but it's close to what the
sentiment was now Martin isn't it
amazing that this very power that is
quoting this verse controls the entire
economy and everything that goes in and
out and then they quote
Q which is a little bit outdated
although this comes from the 11th of
November to
2024 yeah I think he's still active oh
you think he's working behind the
scenes the fact Q posted the list of
Rothchild central banks and Elon Musk
xed it shows the US space force is aware
of the nature of what they are dealing
with these central banks create money
out of nothing and this is literally
sucking the life force out of this
planet for example they are pushing
decarbonization based on lies about
carbon the ultimate controllers of the
system are the Vatican named after vatia
the goddess of the underworld and the
black Sun
organization when we went to visit them
they said their God was a black hole in
the center of the Galaxy this stained
glass from the cathedral in Milan shows
a black hole with light around it so
what this is a a web page that is well
let's say not very favorable no it's now
again like The Times of Israel was
speaking much more for the cons liberal
side this is again speaking for the the
conservative side this eelan dialectic
yes but they recognize the Vatican as a
danger but the conservative side is
actually furthering the aims yeah of the
Vatican now Sylvester Stallone had
something interesting to say shall we
listen to what he had to say sure when I
did Rocky if you remember the first
image was a picture of Jesus and it says
Resurrection AC Club I found a church
that had been converted to a boxing ring
so the image pans down from Jesus onto
Rocky being hit and at that moment he
was a chosen person and that's how I
began the journey something was going to
happen this man was going to go through
a metamorphosis and change lives just
like President Trump we are
the presence of a really mythical
character I love mythology and this
individual does not exist on this planet
nobody in the world could have pulled
off what he pulled off so I'm in
awe when George Washington defended his
country he had no idea that he was going
to change the world because without him
you could imagine what the world would
look like guess what we got the second
George Washington
congratulations shall we remind the
American public that Washington was a
high Freemason I think it might be
necessary because a lot of people don't
know that and that all the cornerstones
that were laid by him were Masonic
cornerstones for all those illustrious
buildings which make up government
M and Martin what's also interesting to
me when he refers to this one that had
received a beating Rocky something great
was going to to happen to him and he was
going to be basically you know become a
Superman a
superpower and the cross over there was
a symbol for that and Donald Trump had
this beat up image and then he rose to
the occasion what about the Catholic
Church same didn't it receive a mortal
wound yeah it seemed like a seemed like
a mortal wound wasn't it supposed to
rise like the fex out of the ashes isn't
that the mural in the United Nations
yeah and who were the great thinkers
Behind these organizations that actually
started all of these things the
bilderbergers and all the organizations
that led again to the regathering of
humanity under one Tower of Babel
weren't they all high Masons and
Catholic agents for sure now Donald
Trump
claims to have a Protestant background
right Presbyterian yeah but his wife is
staunch Catholic and when they went to
the pope of course they were dressed
accordingly to the traditions and four
years ago he praised
Catholicism and this time round at that
famous dinner that Cala decided not to
attend it did exactly the same yeah so
what is his relationship with
Catholicism let him speak for himself
now more than ever our nation needs a
renewal of the values this organization
promotes and that the Catholic faithful
live out each and every day in peace we
love the Catholic people we love the
Catholic religion and above all we
respect it greatly as president I will
always support you in your effort to
serve our fellow citizens and to lift up
all Humanity I will protect the Catholic
church and I will defend the rights of
religious Believers of every race
religion color and Creed we're at the
alith dinner of course tell me why did
you decide it was important to be here
and what message is commala Harris
sending by not being here to Catholic
voters well I think you're honoring the
Catholic church and you know I've been
uh longtime supporter and I'm surprised
she's not here I think she's the first
one in many many in decades actually to
miss it a candidate who was always been
a tradition so I'm happy only that the
Catholics are going to vote for Trump
now but uh no look I have a special
relationship with the Catholic church
and I uh I think it was very important
to be here yeah uh I've been noticing on
your social media posts on your at your
rallies you're playing the a Maria
you're posting happy birthday Mary a St
Michael prayer to ward off evil is that
telling voters something about your
spiritual Journey what is that no I
don't think so it's just beautiful to me
I mean I I look at the whole thing the
words and the pictures the pictures are
so beautiful and uh yeah I put up some
stuff somebody else asked me that same
question and it's really that I think
it's really very beautiful the pope was
asked about your candidacy and KLA
Harris and he instructed Catholic voters
to vote for the lesser of two evils who
do you think he means and why well I
think he wants them to vote for me and I
stand for really everything that you
stand for and that the church stands for
and she doesn't she's a a very different
kind of a person she's a Marxist her
father was a Marxist and still is a
Marxist and they are not big into
religion I will tell you and I'm not
just talking about the Catholic religion
I'm talking about any religion uh the
whole Democrat Party has gone really
radical left and I'm the opposite I am
totally in favor of religion and I also
like the Catholic Church a lot well
Martin going to get any clearer
I can't say that you can what else can
you say to make it more clear do you
remember that he knelt down before this
image of John Paul
II so the these are all very interesting
things and we need these Supermen to
make the fix rise out of the ashes so
let's see what they have in mind in
terms of that that the X-Men have now
arrived in reality to rescue the
Republic this is a transformation that
is not yet been fully noted even by the
Trump campaign itself despite its truly
and surre revolutionary nature first and
foremost among these new supporters and
colleagues of the former president is
Elon Musk he truly is and so comically
an ex-man as is starkly evidenced by the
new name of the controversial social
media platform he now owns and was once
known as Twitter he has been struggling
to build X the everything platform for
decades with that particular moniker in
his mind the whole time the X-Men like
The Avengers was a group of Misfit
mutants who came together to save the
normies from the various Monsters of the
world it is frequently the case that
life imitates art and there were perhaps
real reason stirring in the collective
unconscious of the West inclining us to
look toward the eccentric and
supernormal for our Salvation fiction
meets reality in the strangest of ways
in any case Trump is now playing Charles
Xavier to a strange group of mutants or
if the similar metaphor of the Avengers
is more attractive conceptually Captain
America to the god and
superheroes Tony Stark billionaire
although importantly without the arms
dealing the six of them together Trump
musos Kennedy gabard ramaswami and Vance
should be able to keep every single
member in check and that bodess well for
the creativity productivity and
stability of the future Trump X-Men team
Administration wouldn't all you daring
and so Cinema obsessed theatrical
Americans love to have the adventure
that such a mutant group of strange
personalities running the show would
offer for the next four years or longer
Trump musk Kennedy gabard
ramaswami Vance that's a dream team mtin
if that's a dream team do you think it's
associated with the dream of Daniel
John the Revelator that's brilliantly
put yes definitely I think this could be
very interesting because I'm also one
who studies the
dreams especially of Daniel and the
Revelation excellently put now Martin so
when it comes to this dream team that
has now sort of taken the Reigns in the
United States of
America then uh they also must have
certain ideologies of of course which
are in line with the Jesuit
picture now the Jesuits created futurism
yeah in order to take the heat of the
papacy as the Antichrist
system and uh of course Israel plays a
major part in that although Jesus had
said the house is desolate and that we
are now living in the time of spiritual
Israel so to bring in that ideology and
to make a literal Temple a reality you
have to be very pro-israel right yeah
now the Bible is very clear that the
temple is not a temple of stone but ye
are the Temple of the Living God Living
Stones built into a spiritual house not
a physical house so all of these
ideologies are coming together Martin
but they are underpinned by Jesuit
theologies and counter theologies as far
as the Reformation is concerned yes wow
we're in for a for an interesting time
president Trump has been the best the
best president for Israel and for the
Middle East In Our Lifetime we have to
get president Trump back in as the
commanderin-chief the Jewish Community
needs it the world needs it America
needs it and I just want to take a
moment to salute you and thank and let's
take take America back and let's stand
shoulder-to-shoulder with the greatest
Ally we've ever known the state of
Israel as we fight
evil all over the world you're seeing a
scrambling all over the Middle East of
countries suddenly trying to behave
differently because they know a new
sheriff has come to town and this isn't
a one bullet Barney with a bullet in his
shirt pocket this is the real deal I
mean this is Donald Trump that they are
afraid of and just ecstatic that he has
asked me to be part of uh what I think
is going to be not just a realignment of
political parties and many institutions
in America but really the world to bring
peace that we desperately need and quite
frankly when I look at all these people
that he's picked uh I'm incredibly
impressed with all of them I feel like
that I'm a you know a 1995 Ford pickup
trying to enter the nd500 I don't see
myself in the same view as I do some of
these wonderful people he's picked but
I'm honored Beyond even description to
be able to serve my country and this
president in a nation that I've been
traveling to since July of
1973 when I was 17 made about a 100
trips there and I couldn't be more
grateful to this president for giving me
the opportunity to serve the country and
him I would imagine if the elite stonic
that lectured the pramas professors uh
before Congress uh if that at least
stonic shows up at the United Nations um
that's going to be a little bit of a a
shakeup the likes of which maybe we
haven't seen in our lifetime that could
be
entertaining it'll be very entertaining
but more importantly it's going to be a
great revelation of what's wrong at the
UN and why for uh many years I've never
understood why we kept dumping money
into it I've often said get a jackhammer
uh hammer the thing right off and float
it into the East River and invite any
country who thinks they could enjoy it
to have it she's not going to be invited
to a lot of uh after uh five cocktail
parties in Manhattan where she'll be
saluted by the swells but that's not why
she's going and it's why she's going to
be terrific in that position she's bold
strong unafraid and will take nothing
off of any of them and we need to be
bold there's no reason that you have
people like Iran and communist China on
human rights committees talking about
human rights when they violate them more
than anybody so it's time for a complete
reset of our internal and international
relationships that's what Donald Trump
is clearly setting out to do and I
couldn't be more delighted to see this
take place you're partnering with the
smartest guy in the country there's no
doubt about it uh and the richest guy
but um you look at Elon Musk and he's a
genius if you can figure out a way to go
save those astronauts that are Lost in
Space God bless you I could never figure
that out in 500 lifetimes um so I admire
that he's talking about $2 billion in
cuts by identifying waste Fraud and
Abuse is that a realistic number that's
a big
number yeah two billion isn't a big
number but two trillion is Sean and
that's what we're looking at here look
two trillion I stand corrected no no I
want to be very clear about the scale I
want to be very clear about the scale
that we're thinking here we're not
thinking small we're playing big here
because we have a once- in a generation
mandate right now the American people
have voted for Dr IC reform of the
government and our federal government is
broken it's no secret that it is a
fourth branch of government the
administrative state that makes most of
the rules that creates a federal
bureaucracy that's hampering our economy
so what do we want to do we want to go
in and slash and burn that bureaucracy
to help Americans stimulate the economy
and to restore self-governance against
Sean the people we elect to run the
government they're not even the ones who
run the government anymore it's these
unelected bureaucrats Republican
politicians have talked about fixing
this for a long time not with a lot of
progress so I do think it's going to
take a couple of Outsiders Elon and I
have built a great friendship over the
last year we're working together
intensely and we're not going to stop
till we get the job done anyway so if
that if that's George sorus of the right
that's me
okay I'm incredibly excited about the
future and
uh the public has given us a mandate
that is could not be more clear it's the
clearest mandate the the the people have
spoken the people want change they will
get what they ask
for I think this is going to be the most
transformative presidency perhaps since
the founding of the country and
president Trump is picking the cabinet
to do it you can see the the choices are
people who are actually going to make
change it's not going to be business as
usual we're going to shake things up
it's going to be a revolution and we're
headed towards I think a fantastic
future I'm super excited I look forward
to experiencing that with everyone thank
you I've made it a living hell for the
swamp rats and many of them are retiring
now in fact CNN just ran an article
blaming me for their
departures you are welcome Mullen you
see when I offer these critiques that
include the conduct of some fellow
Republicans I catch a lot of heat don't
get me wrong
I'd prefer to just fight the Democrats
but if the Republicans are going to
dress up like Democrats in drag then I
will lead the fight against them too
they seem to be fired up yeah and
they're talking about shaking up the
United Nations mhm shaking up Iran and
China and all of them now prophecy tells
me that this second beast will force the
entire world to to give homage to the
first piece yeah so Martin in order to
do that there must be enough teeth
that's for sure so there must be a real
shakeup because right now um America's
image is somewhat tarnished don't you
think and you can see that these people
mean
business
so do you
think they can be um something up the
sleeve of the Democrats still so Martin
do the Democrats have something up their
sleeve well Martin they could have
something up their sleeve there are two
possibilities here and either one fits
it doesn't really matter because the the
watch word is orto up you have to get
order out of chaos so the one scenario
is they take a back seat and they have
played their role in bringing the eelan
dialectic to the point where it is now
where the public has said enough of this
far extreme stuff let's move to the
other side and see if we can get this
pendulum to go where the scriptures said
it should go right that's the one
extreme the other possibility is you
know how about telling Russia we're
going to allow missiles to be fired
right at you
no matter where you are and let's
escalate it so that we have World War
II and uh it's interesting that Sweden
and Finland have warned their public
that we are heading for that war they
just did that now again that it is
highly likely that that war will now
take place well then Martin then you
could have an interesting situation
because under those circumstances you
could have martial law and all of this
might not even be implemented wouldn't
that be interesting well uh it will
probably be war and Civil War and
everything in between so there will
really be chaos but let's hope that uh
that doesn't play out because the Bible
also says you know peace peace yeah
peace and safety and then sudden
destruction so maybe for a short time
there we don't know what's going to
happen but certainly we're in for a ride
and that's and then what's the other
scenario well mtin we also are told in
the scriptures there will be a time of
trouble such as never was but that could
be associated with the implementation of
the mark of the beast and the AR of the
math thereof uh another trick up the
sleeve would be if Biden retired yeah
what if he retired and said well let's
give the Reigns to camela then we we
will have a female president and if we
then get martial law then it'll get even
more interesting so these are all
possibilities we will we will watch the
movie and see which one plays out right
exactly this is an interesting movie but
anyway the way it's playing out now with
this Administration fits perfectly with
the biblical picture absolutely so the
other ones would be surprise moves but
the end game would still be the same
exactly the same just like Kevin Roberts
said so Kevin Roberts what else does he
have to say about the admin
Administration a lot of people to talk
to and look I'm I'm I'm looking at these
things happen pretty fast uh let's see
Marco Rubio apparently going to be
Secretary of State Christie n Homeland
Security secretary Lee zeldon in charge
of the EPA cash Patel somewhere in the
intelligence Community not quite sure
where Alise stonic is going to be the
ambassador of the United Nations and the
list goes on I commented you had a smile
on your face just before we came on you
do Donald Trump won and so therefore and
by the way the house is now officially
secured for the Republicans so it is a
trifecta and I look at some of these
appointments I mean obviously you must
be pleased we are steering the country
back away from the brink and hopefully
back down the road in a normal fashion
when you see some of
these appointments are you
pleased honestly I'm ecstatic I mean
this this is exceeding our expectations
and our expectations were high because
president-elect Trump of course has a
proven record he's also obviously has
the profile of a CEO and you and I and
so many in your audience know that great
CEOs understand that they don't have the
answers to all of the questions the one
thing that they do really well is
appoint talented people to develop those
answers and Implement plans and so from
his appointment of Susie WS as his chief
of staff to my friend Stephen Miller as
Deputy Chief of Staff and of course I do
have to say my favorite which would
surprise no one including the
president-elect Tom Homan our visiting
fellow at the Heritage Foundation is
borders are who's already just sending
signals that you better go back if
you're here illegally but all of the
names that you mentioned and then some
that are rumored to be named in the next
couple of days this has the making Steve
of one of the best cabinets in modern
American history and that is fitting
because there is a lot of work ahead
yeah this is like an All-Star group this
is like the Avengers I mean I hate to go
there but it's kind of what we're
looking at here if you think about those
in the intelligence in the in the state
department area if in fact the the
rumors are true that Senator Rubio will
be appointed we also know that our
friend Congressman Mike Waltz will be
National Security adviser just take
these two men as examples these two guys
of course grew up as sons of the Reagan
Revolution emphasizing a foreign policy
Mantra of peace through strength they
understand and have been explicit
especially in recent years that peace
through strength is not neoconservative
adventurism as we saw under the George W
Bush Administration but rather making
sure that our enemies fear us so Martin
that just confirms again that uh all of
those appointees are in line with the
Heritage Foundation yeah with project
2025 does that contain Sunday
legislation 100% 100% and it will
default to Sunday yes even if you keep
another day it says in that document
quite plainly you know that document
does make room for another day MH like
the Seventh Day Adventist keep or some
other groups but you can't please
everybody and the default will be Sunday
yeah now when they're talking about
synchronized free time then it can only
be one day Sunday because the issue is
the family and uh I was watching an
article or reading an article on the
Heritage Foundation and what it is
saying and this
Administration that the central issue is
to put the family back in the center
that's Catholic that's exactly what the
pope is standing for and that is why
they're talking about synchronized free
time now in order to do that you must
get this religious aspect back into the
education system so the Bible has to
come back as a as a door stop of course
but it's there it says historical
document and of course some of these uh
extreme views must be rescinded they
must become more aligned to the ideology
of the Ten Commandments Etc and the left
is going crazy and saying the church is
you know invading the territory that it
shouldn't invade according to the
Constitution so there was an interesting
discussion on CNN on this issue and uh I
think it's worthwhile listening to that
one this is brand new stuff yeah as you
know your State's Attorney General's
office says you don't have the authority
for this mandate to play that prayer
video so what Authority do you have to
mandate schools to show your prayer
video where you also pray for
president-elect
Trump look I've continued to hear the
gaslighting from the left um and frankly
even from this network pushing lies
about what's going on across America
president Trump has a clear mandate he
wants prayer back in school he wants
radical leftism out of the class wants
our kids to be patriotic want parents
back in charge with school choice we are
acting upon that agenda here in Oklahoma
that's what our parents want every
County in Oklahoma voted for President
Trump his agenda is crystal clear and
we're going to enact it in the state of
Oklahoma all right first of all the
Constitution is not crystal clear on
that it doesn't have God in it there is
this establishment clause in the First
Amendment which the Supreme Court has
routinely said it requires the
separation of church and state and
public schools there are many cases that
there hold on I'm speaking there are
many cases where the Supreme Court has
routinely ruled on that you went after
woke teachers and the radical left in
your announcement for attacking
religious liberty but your critics are
saying that by requiring Bibles in every
classroom and requiring this prayer
video you're trying to impose your
religion on students in violation of The
Establishment Clause they say the
Constitution Scholars say the
Constitution is crystal clear on freedom
of religion not in forcing one religion
your religion on students what do you
say look CNN doesn't have to like it uh
left-wing activists don't have to like
it I'm just talking about facts it's not
my opinion document the Bible is a
historical document you can't rewrite
history okay I'm not saying that the
Bible isn't an important part of
understanding this what I'm saying is
your critics including a lot of parents
are saying you're trying to enforce your
religion um your specific religion
Christianity onto students not just by
requiring Bibles in every classroom but
also by requiring this prayer video as
well uh where you also pray for for
Donald Trump just last week this federal
judge ruled its unconstitutional for the
Ten Commandments to be shown in a
classroom how is what you're trying to
do
different well it's a it's a radical
federal judge way out of step with the
American people in the Constitution
here's the reality we have the right to
express our religious beliefs we
absolutely do that doesn't stop at a
Schoolhouse I was crystal clear in there
we're not telling kids they have to pray
but we are telling kids they have the
right to pray if they so choose you know
look you're talking about how important
the Bible is in US history and the
founding of the country um but this was
a country that was not founded on a
specific religion and that if if you are
really if it's important to talk about
religious texts and how it how it weaves
into the history of the US then why not
also include the the Quran why not also
include the Book of Mormon um why not
also include these other religious
texts well let's talk about this for a
second and everyone who signed that list
everybody suing me they're the same
people that want gender queer and flamer
in the classroom under the guys not
necessarily true you're you are painting
everyone with a broad brush the Bible's
the most read book in American history
and the left doesn't want our kids to
know anything about it they don't want
kids to understand that it played a huge
role in American history that is
academic malpractice we have to get back
to teaching American exceptionalism
American values where those things came
from that's just history and the left
doesn't have you're not answering my
question about these other religious
text if that is your reason if you were
like I want our students to learn about
the founding of this country and the
Bible played a big role and and and that
then why not include other religious
texts that also throughout history
played a role such as as I pointed out
the Book of Mormon such as you know uh
the
Quran sure look in at world history
class you can absolutely talk about
those but let's be clear in American
history the Bible played a unique role
in shaping this history and you said no
religion Thomas Jefferson said our
rights came from God and again look
maybe we all need to go back and study
some of this especially on CNN to
understand the Thomas Jefferson rejected
part of Christian doctrine Thomas
Jefferson promoted freedom of religion
one of his top three accomplishments on
his gravestone is promoting a law in
Virginia for the freedom of religion so
if you want and then John Adams would
you say that John Adams is a key founder
of the United States do you think he is
absolutely talk John Adams signed a
treaty in 1797 saying the government of
the United States of America is not in
any sense founded on the Christian
religion that was an interesting
discussion I think the CNN spokesperson
had a point on a few on a few of those
things on a few of those things and of
course he is he's using it to his
advantage and uh interesting that he
uses the term
gaslighting interesting discussion well
but M they are implementing a certain
religion
sure and just why we saying that she had
some good points is because a lot of
people will probably be very agitated
when we say that but it is that you
don't
legislate religion you can't legislate
religion but if they're going to go in
this route then the very first thing
that they will want to do to protect the
family is to bring in synchron IED rest
so that means Sunday legislation and
that is the mark of the beast whether we
like it or whether we don't like it
people say how can you say that Rome
says it not we she says it is the mark
of our ecclesiastical power that we have
changed the day of rest from Saturday to
Sunday and by the way the Sabbath day
has a definite article that means
there's only one you can't pick and
choose which one you want so are they
going to go that route what is the
discussion in this regard should we
listen to some of these statements yes
we could keep going on that but the big
thing that you're right like we kind of
got to talk about I really want to talk
about it Christian States you know like
like government you're right yeah so so
you're talking about like every
government in the world and tell me tell
me if I'm wrong because this is how I'm
understanding it every government in the
world should enforce laws that everyone
has to rest on the Sabbath
um and everyone has
to cast out Idols cannot practice
idolatry in any fashion and they have to
put God
first so no that's extreme I'm not
saying that every nation should do that
I'm saying every nation will do that
because I'm not only a theonomous Mike I
also happen to be post-millennial so I
was was being factious I I know I don't
think that's extreme I think you're
absolutely right what you just said is
my view and not only do I think it
should be done by every nation I think
it will be I I I truly believe I think
the nations are Christ in think it
should be done yes I do should and will
not just should but will so so we should
uh as Christians we should then all of
us be working together to ensure that
minimally The Ten Commandments are
enforced through governmental laws
across the
country so no Sports on Sundays or
Saturdays I'm assuming that you would
think the Sabbath is actually Saturday
no no no no no no so so both Westminster
and 16 no you're right side issue no no
but yeah so so the um both both
Westminster and 169 the reform view is
they're they're all sabbatarian but they
would say that uh the Sabbath has been
not removed but renewed by Christ who is
Lord of the Sabbath by virtue of his
resurrection from the last day of the
week to the first uh is what is what the
um 1689 and Westminster Confession say
and I you can push back w't even push
back on yeah of course you can push back
on it I'm just but I'm just articulating
my position that that's I would stay
with the Sabbath but yes the Sabbath I
think Nations should observe Sabbath
keeping
laws
Martin he's very biblical in that point
of view oh for sure definitely spot on
all right unfortunately you you're not
supposed to want to climb on that bang
wagon oh I understand so Martin if the
Bible says this is going to happen and
he says it will happen from a totally
different perspective not a
but from a Reconstructionist
perception then you know the dovetailing
between what scripture says and what
they are doing is just amazing it's
amazing so Martin when they actually go
this
far as is written in their
documents then Martin can we expect that
great time of trouble and the
persecution that goes along with it the
no buying and selling and eventually a
death decree this same person that we
just watched remember there quite a
while back we we showed videos where
they said this is Christian country if
you don't like it get out get out
correct so in the last great conflict
let's quote from the spirit of
Prophecy of the controversy with Satan
those who are loyal to God will see
every Earthly support cut off because
they refuse to break his law in
obedience to Earthly Powers they will be
forbidden to buy or sell
it will finally be decreed that they
shall be put to death that's from the
Bible
directly but to the obedient is given
the promise he shall dwell on high his
place of Defense shall be the Munitions
of rocks bread shall be given him his
water shall be sure quoting Isaiah
33:16 by This Promise the children of
God will live when the Earth shall be
wasted with famine they shall be fed
they shall not be ashamed shamed in the
evil time and in the days of famine they
shall be satisfied quoting Psalms
37:19 at that time of distress the
prophet habac looked forward and his
words Express the faith of the church
although the Fig Tree shall not blossom
neither shall the fruit be in the vines
the labor of the olive shall fail and
the fields shall yield no meat the flock
shall be cut off from the fold and there
shall be no herd in the Stalls yet will
I rejoice in the Lord I will joy in the
god of my
salvation so M that's what's in stall
for God's people according to the
scriptures the second beast is making an
image of the first Beast the second past
is Raising its voice and telling the
Nations shape up or ship out does it
also speak like a dragon it speaks like
a dragon when it enforces legislation
to control conscience and particularly
legislation that is contrary to the word
of God but in harmony with
Rome then we are at the point where the
wound is healed and the whole world
worshiped and wondered after the Beast
may the Lord give us
wisdom I am
hopeful that we can soon see the
termination of this catastrophe I which
is called
a planet in Rebellion against the
government of God I agree let's
pray Heavenly
Father the scriptures are
clear the pieces of the puzzle are
coming
together and you have said when we see
these things we should lift up our heads
because our Salvation draweth
nigh I believe our Salvation draweth
nigh and I pray that in the outpouring
of the latter rain many eyes will be
opened see the Trap that has been laid
and avoid it by hiding under the shadow
of your wing is my prayer in jesus' name
amen amen
[Music]
[Applause]